just over a year ago the small town of
Paradise California was nearly destroyed
by a wildfire but now those who are
rebuilding have a new reason to cheer
the town's high school football team is
dominating rivals this season tomorrow
they could move one step closer to a
state championship
Jonathan Vigliotti is in Los Angeles
sending a lot of folks are cheering them
on tell me about that game hey good
morning to you Michelle Happy
Thanksgiving a Black Friday the Paradise
Bobcats are undefeated for the first
time in 15 years it's hard to believe
considering what this team has been
through one player telling me it's not
just about winning but replanting the
roots of this lost town on this Friday
Night Lights shine on a 12 and ot not
because of its winning record but
because of the lawsuits had to overcome
to get here we have so much more to play
for than just football it's been a year
since the most destructive wildfire in
California history ripped through
Paradise killing 86 people and
destroying about 14,000 homes the front
door would be right there most of the
players including running back Lucas
Hartley lost everything like many others
his family had to leave the area last
year's team was forced to forfeit their
season and faced an uncertain future
nobody wants to tell the victim story
anymore everyone wants to tell a story
about moving forward to do that they've
returned to the field many driving 40
minutes each way to get to practice
there's still only three kids living in
Paradise football brings some normalcy
for them so they want to win they want
to be successful and it gives them kind
of an escape from all the other issues
that are going on from being displaced
from the fire after the fire it's more
of a motivation to come out and have our
town on our backs and prove that after
everything else happened that we can
come back stronger than we were before
and their dedication to the game is
reenergized their community the see on
play with the heart that they're playing
with
fantastic we have something to prove
it's incredible how many people have
been coming out to the games we show up
to games an hour two hours three hours
away and we'll go in pack the visitors
side by number more people than the home
team sometimes that support has helped
push them to a perfect season win or
lose this Saturday these teens have
already become hometown heroes just
gives people hope that we can rebuild it
gives people hope that they can come
back and live their lives here again and
those who can't come back it just gives
them a little piece of what they lost
and to give you an idea of just how
supportive their fans are the fire force
about 95% of the community to leave
right now fewer than 2,000 people still
live in the town but reportedly three
times that number 6,000 fans show up on
Friday nights to watch the Bobcats take
the field
Jericka Jonathan thank you what a great
story and just goes to show you how
something like football just brings a
community together well Friday Night
Lights are already a big deal but this
takes it to a new level I'll never
forget covering it you know there's one
major road going in and out of paradise
and there were cars just lined up for
miles where people had literally
abandoned their vehicles and take it off
running just to try and survive they'll
get never forget that